the definition of the conditional PDF is
very simple it is just this formula
which is analogous to the one for the
discrete case in all respects
mathematical and intuitive it is very
similar to the conditional pmf even so
developing a solid grasp of this concept
does take some further thinking so we
will now make some observations that
should be helpful in this respect a
first and obvious observation is that
the conditional PDF is non-negative it's
defined when the denominator is positive
the numerator is a non-negative quantity
so it's always a non-negative quantity a
more interesting observation is that for
any given value of little Y the
conditional PDF looks like a slice of
the joint PDF indeed if you fix the
value of little Y then the denominator
in this definition is a constant and we
have a function that varies with X
that's the same way that the joint PDF
varies with X pictorially let us
consider this particular joint PDF and
let this be the x-axis and let that be
the y-axis if we fix a certain value of
y if we condition on Y having taken this
particular value so that our universe is
now this particular line on that
universe the value of the denominator in
this definition is a constant and the
conditional PDF is going to vary
according to the height of the joint on
that particular conditional universe so
the height of the joint if we trace
is one of those curves up here and goes
down so it is really a slice taken out
of the joint PDF if we condition on a
different Y we get a different slice of
the joint PDF and so on actually the
conditional is not exactly the same as
the slice we also have this term on the
denominator that serves as a scaling
factor it turns out that this scaling
factor is exactly what we need for the
conditional PDF given a specific value
of little Y to integrate to one indeed
if we fix little Y and take the integral
over all X's using the definition and
because this term is a constant and does
not involve X we only need to integrate
the numerator and we recognize that the
numerator corresponds to our earlier
formula for the marginal distribution
the marginal PDF of Y from the joint
this is how we recover the marginal PDF
of Y so the numerator turns out to be
the same as the denominator and so we
get a ratio of 1 therefore the
conditional PDF for a given value of the
random variable Y behaves in all
respects like an ordinary PDF it is
non-negative and it integrates to 1 the
last observation is that we can take
this definition and move the denominator
to the other side to obtain this formula
which has the familiar form of the
multiplication rule the probability of
two events happening is the probability
of the first times the probability of
the second given the first except that
here were not really dealing with
probabilities we're dealing with
densities by symmetry a similar formula
must also be true when we interchange
the role
of x and y so algebraically everything
is similar to what we have seen for the
case of discrete random variables it's
the same form of the multiplication rule
although the interpretation is a bit
different because densities are not
probabilities